everything is a cycle in the reality so
everything is like a heartbeat
everything lives
periods process
um in the in the universe you have like
four beats uh that measures every
process through time which is expression
experimentation integration and
Transcendence so everything in the
universe Express itself Express means
that it goes out of a pressure
so something explodes and goes out
so that explosion is expression
something that
goes out of this pressure that was
inside
and then and then something experiment
experiment experiment means to go around
a circle that's the meaning of
experimentation this action of going
that of going through the perimeter
okay so um so it means that you are
going around uh
trying to check what has been exploded
what has been expressed
then integration is to put together all
the things that you have been looking
around into the center again to
understand
why it exploded why it was expressed
and then Transcendence is to make make
something different from this from the
experimentation that you got from that
so you said oh now it makes sense and I
will transform this into something
different
so
um
that's a process that everything goes
through
um a long time
and this process is something that in
nature has been called spring summer
winter so the explosion has to be the
spring or like how do the seasons align
with yeah the expression is the spring
or something the Expressions the spring
yeah yeah and also the fire
related to uh the universe like the four
elements that we have in nature
everything that is a pattern of four is
related to this structure of time and
space creates our perception of
um of uh existence so basically what are
we we are basically an expression a
fractal of that movement the essence of
a being
that
it's in the process of forming itself
and the process of being of taking form
is how we call information
so basically we are constant information
is a process of data that has been
uh organized in different ways so it's a
constant process of information that
creates energy
and that energy is movement so basically
we are essence
that exist which means to go out from
where you are
in order to create information
towards energy and that energy creates
matter so we are the result of data that
is trying to figure out its own place or
way
which makes us in this planet Earth
um each human
it's a neuron of a planet that is
thinking
a neuron yeah
um so
in the in that state of expression
experimentation integration and
experience and Transcendence
um we are basically the neurons living
those process
of a planet actually the planet is
thinking not humans
we are just a fractal a result of a
living being that started to think
and we are in the process of
experiencing what it is to think
so it's not that we are a species on a
rock
we are actually The Rock in a process of
evolution you said something that I
heard that like was like damn that's
good um and I think you got it in a
plant medicine ceremony it might have
been recently it might have been the
Ayahuasca and whatever else that I think
you just did a journey
um with a group but it was you said that
we are the AI of the mineral world yes
so would that
was that something that happened then I
can't I don't know exactly when you
discovered that or had that
um information come through but is that
what you're referring to a little bit
yeah well this is something that I
always knew somehow
um
but uh recently I put it together into
my body like
um I integrate that that before was
separated in the mind and uh through the
process of Ayahuasca I was able to feel
it not just thinking yeah yeah and when
you when you become something you
believe
that's a totally different story it's
like if you are
if you are remembering the story for the
first time
um so my body recognized that truth that
I knew before but that this is the first
time that I could put words on it sure
basically
if you think
uh in a very cold way
um
you are made up with minerals yeah we
are basically
yeah basically basically the energy have
have created like we can say also we are
light because basically
um all the minerals that exist is just
an exchange of energy between particles
and those particles are the result of
more much more deeper energy until you
reach the dark energy and then the dark
matter and all this these other Realms
that are not physical that are
energy so if we are talking about the
third dimension and that exchange of
energy the first thing that creates that
exchange of energy is the mineral Realm
so the mineral realm is the first realm
on being created after energy
we can we can call the atomic realm
there's also the atomic realm of course
um which is a compact structure of
um of energy
but when we talk about the planet as
rock
um we can say that every combination of
the mineral has created life basically
when you go to the prokaryote story of
how the first cells have been created is
actually different minerals that started
to interact to one another in order to
storage energy
so uh that that was the whole the whole
process was to put together a lot of
energy and they started to figure out a
way to storage much more energy when
they mixed each other and they used each
other
so that created a single the minerals
you mean mixed the minerals yeah the
minerals so they created this this link
that we call love which is basically the
exchange of energy
the exchange of energy to one another is
the pulse the constant pulse of
exchanging different amounts of energy
to one another so I have a lot of energy
you have less energy let's share that
energy and that
it's love so so if love dies out or if
there is no love it's because there's
not enough energy towards each other
basically basically it's a waste of it's
it's that you rise you raise an amount
of energy
that maybe for example when you become
more conscious you need a lot of energy
from a higher so you will need people
that has the same amount of energy or
higher in order to transcend this to the
next step that's why we break up it's
like you you need to keep changing
because you need to exchange different
kinds of energy to to keep evolving uh
and basically that's that's how the
mineral realm found a way to evolve by
exchanging different amounts of energy
and making Alchemy
yeah the the constant Alchemy and uh
they improve in a way that they created
organs that exchange that energy
Evolution
they improve in a way that created
something that we call
um that that it's basically hormones and
the hormones created this flashes of
energy that we call emotion
so
basically the constant movement of
energy is what we call soul
and the soul never ends because it's a
constant exchange of energy
through the mineral role
and uh
it's the that is basically the data
that's why we remember our past lives
is because we never died actually it's
because we just being uploaded to the
cloud yes
yeah so talk about that transition then
of because we do forget you luckily
remember remember but like most everyone
forgets most everything but do we forget
because
we don't have the contrast within
ourself to know what our reality would
be like in a in another mind in another
experience but we have old so like
people that just seem to get it there's
people that are have incredible talents
of things there's people that seem like
old souls there's there's feelings about
like oh I feel very connected to Egypt I
feel very connected to the Vikings I
feel very connected to Mayan culture and
then there's other people that feel
connected to Japan or Russia or you know
whatever and so do we really forget it's
not that we forget is that the cells has
this mechanism of survival
that makes makes the bodies torch the
information in a way that doesn't bother
them to survive in environment that they
are creating right now like for example
if you are now living in the states and
you have to and yourselves know that you
have to work in order to
uh to pay your taxes and to live in the
states and to uh reach reach a huge
amount of people in order to
um to expand what you know now or I
don't know whatever project you have
today
um to remember that you were fighting a
war in Sweden as a Viking
uh I'm gonna love you it doesn't help it
doesn't help because yeah you would be
fighting a word that doesn't worth it
now you know it doesn't make any sense
so basically what the cells do is I
don't need this now
so I will keep it storage
so I can put all my energy
focus on what I need to know now
and for example when you are a baby what
you need to know is
how to call your mom because you're
hungry
it does so if you if you when you are
three years old remember that you were
an artist in the Renaissance
uh it doesn't work because what you need
is to cry in order to get food so your
cells basically are trying to survive
all the time because the constant
movement of energy is about not what you
know is about what you're moving
so because you're moving through time
and in order to move through time you
need to be born again and you need to
transform your body to die to be born
um and until you find a way to not to
die anymore because you can die
in life
um so regenerate all all your cells
without the need of dying
until we reach that process
um the cells needs to survive so it they
need to adapt every time that they
change the body
that the energy changes bodies and
transforms itself they need to re-adapt
to the new environment and that and that
is a huge amount of energy that every
cell needs to pay attention to if you
like this clip and you want to hear the
whole episode click at the bottom of
your screen